[Music]  how would you describe what the circle  is to say your grandmother the chaos of  the web made elegance speed round Paul  or John early Paul late John Mario asana  really sonic late Mario needs of the  society or needs of the individual  should be the same you're most scared of  unfulfilled potential I am a believer in  the perfectibility of human beings  we are our best selves the possibilities  are endless  at the circle there isn't a problem that  we cannot solve we can cure any disease  and we can and hunger without secrets  without the hoarding of knowledge and  information we can finally realize our  potential circles do you like to share  we will see it all  if it happens we'll know  imagine the human rights implications  there needs to be accountability  what is this the circle has a power to  changed everything  so we our lives have got us in trouble  things we hide we care about everybody  you care about  because knowing is good  yes better  [Music]